any advice to someone who wants to make
someone their mentor or is that
something that just can't happen where
oh yeah I'm gonna look up yeah Roger
Corman yeah let's make him happy my
mentor I think it's a lot easier than
you think to sort of find your own
mentor I think especially you know
people I think it's true when people say
Hollywood is very much who you know what
they don't tell you is it's very easy to
get to know someone you know you become
a facebook friend with him next thing
you know you're in their office having
coffee you know are you offered it by
someone coffee and you know in the
people in this town will do anything for
coffee you know it's you know or lunch
especially because it's not a meeting
unless you're eating so I think it's
it's or if you're at a film festival and
you see a director that you really like
just go talk to them and sit down I mean
I was just at a festival I was 222
festivals in seven countries this year
but I remember especially at the
Whistler Film Festival in Canada like a
group of film student from Vancouver
came to the screening and then they were
like hey Dan can we buy you lunch after
the screening and pick your brain I was
like you said the magic words you know
and it was great and he's got you know
had along great time you know chatting
with these guys so i think it's i think
it's it's remarkably easy or easier than
people think to reach out to two other
directors especially you know it's
especially if you if you happen to be in
LA or you go to one of these festivals
you know yeah do you think there's a
courting period with a potential mentor
like you knows that this sometimes stuff
is too you know you jump too fast though
certain things and you can scare someone
off well people like that our approach I
think I think the mistake people make
when they're approaching you know
mentors or people for advice is there
always the first thing they often
because I get this now is people say oh
can you read my script or even can you
watch my movie and honestly I don't have
time hurry scripts I barely have time to
read scripts my own scripts or or even
watch a movie is time consuming I'd
rather say look it just talk to me for
its in 15 minutes or longer you know
it's been all the time on the phone
with you I just don't have time to
invest it and also i think my advice to
other filmmakers when they come to me
and they say well I have this script of
this feature is unlike I doubt that you
don't listen to my advice on your
creative vision like it's that's your
baby and you should do whatever you want
with I can give you advice on like
behind the scenes stuff you know agents
and distributors and producers reps and
crew and working with actors in you know
casting and all kinds of things like
that but as far as you know everybody's
got their own idea what their film is
and I'm certainly not going to be the
one to tell them that they're doing
something wrong you know or different or
I don't think my advice is particularly
relevant I can tell people like a lot
most common question I get it so can you
look at my 25 minutes short I'll be like
yeah my advice is cut it I don't need to
see it okay you know so things like that
like are more sort of you know that kind
of nuts and bolts advice that I can do
and I think I see and I think that's the
same one I approached you know other
filmmakers that are more senior to me is
I'm not gonna say oh please read my
script because I know they're not gonna
have time to do it so I I know not to
ask you know it's like okay what else
can I ask them for and you know in food
and the more specific the better like
specifically you know if there's an
actor I want to work with and I co
they've worked on someone else's film
you know i'll try to get a hold of that
director and say okay how is that person
to work with not will you read my script
or did I at least you know and then and
then if I want talking about something
else then I got him on the phone but you
know but that's a good way to start a
conversation so be respectful of their
time I think so yeah everyone yeah
everyone in this town or any town you
know has a limited amount of time and
you know but you never know when you're
going to find a director producer writer
that you respect to and they're in
having a down time you know and they're
between projects or or if they're at a
festival and they've got an hour between
screenings because of the way things are
scheduled it's like okay you know you've
got an hour let's let me buy you lunch
you know
so I think that I think you've got to
kind of be cognizant of what people's
schedules are and and then just find you
find a way to insert yourself into them
you